[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le lundi 10 juillet voici le programme
de ce soir avec la chaleur et les
vacances d'été qui viennent de débuter
les plans d'eau sont pris d'assaut il
est donc important de rappeler certains
gestes à adopter pour éviter les noyades
ce week-end l'assurance la Macif était à
l'île de loisirs des Boucles de Seine
dans le nord des Yvelines pour
sensibiliser les familles ils sont une
centaine à s'être réunies au sein d'un
collectif à Manille léamo il demande
tous la même chose l'enfouissement des
lignes à haute tension dans le quartier
du Buisson selon plusieurs enquêtes il y
aurait des risques potentiels de
leucémie ou de cancer infantile ces
lignes passe au dessus d'une crèche et
de plusieurs écoles on en parle avec nos
invités et puis comme chaque lundi nous
parlerons de sport dans votre 7 8 au
programme un yvelinois au championnat du
monde de natation univelinoise
championne de poker ou encore un bon
match pour le chenecourtois Victor one
bagnat fait le point en deuxième partie
d'émission et ce sera avec vous Michael
el midoro bonsoir alors on parlera
également de tennis ce soir avec vous
avec le tournoi de Wimbledon
avec Caroline Garcia qui a
malheureusement perdu au troisième tour
la viens de Saint-Germain-en-Laye il y a
eu Arthur et knock qui a également perdu
au premier tour on parlera également
mercato avec les nouvelles recrues au FC
Versailles et également au Paris
Saint-Germain et donc ce sera dans notre
partie sport dans cette partie sport
nous serons également avec
Jean-Christophe Maisonneuve bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes préparateur
mental et auteur du livre la performance
d'une vie c'est quoi en quelques mots un
préparateur mental
la préparation mentale c'est quelqu'un
qui accompagne un individu ou un
collectif à développer ses performances
développer son potentiel en travaillant
sur ses habiletés mentales et en
essayant de supprimer le plus
d'interférences possibles c'est à dire
travail sur ces émotions pour gérer le
stress la confiance en soi la
concentration donc on en parlera en
seconde partie d'émission sur ce plateau
également Pierre-Louis Brière bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le fondateur du
collectif citoyen pour l'enfouissement
des lignes à haute tension de
Magny-les-Hameaux pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé de créer ce collectif
qu'est-ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur c'était en mai dernier c'est
ça l'élément déclencheur c'est un peu
personnel c'est que j'ai un fils qui
vient d'avoir un an et en fait on va le
mettre à la crèche en septembre prochain
et la crèche est située juste en dessous
des lignes donc en fait on n'avait pas
vraiment remarqué les lignes en arrivant
bien qu'on habite à 150 mètres et c'est
vraiment voyant on a envie de visiter la
crèche en voyant les lignes juste au
dessus que ça m'a fait un peu réfléchir
donc je me suis un peu renseigné sur les
sujets j'ai vu que dans tous les
rapports officiels ont mentionné
certains risques pour la santé nous
sommes notamment le semis infantile
quand c'est infantile en parlant avec
les habitants plusieurs se plaignaient
notamment de migraines de maux de tête
etc
donc c'est là dessus que voilà j'ai
commencé à réfléchir à ce collectif et
qu'on a pu lancer en mai dernier et il y
a une vraie dynamique donc on en parlera
également plus en détail tout à l'heure
dans quelques instants avec nous
également sur ce plateau une autre
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir bonsoir Mathieu
vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines ce sera juste après les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir un
grand soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau
des températures il fera 20 degrés à
Rambouillet 21 à Houdan 22 à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 23 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le ciel se couvre
légèrement côté température il fera
chaud en moyenne 30 à 31 degrés et
demain nous fêterons la saint Benoît le
point maintenant sur les informations du
jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence les informations du jour
Gabriel par une image très
impressionnante oui impressionnante
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
Mathilde samedi aux alentours de 16h ben
cours a été frappé par une immense
coulée debout la raison les orages
accompagnée d'une pluie de grêlons qui
se sont abattus sur la commune alors
l'épisode n'a duré qu'une vingtaine de
minutes mais les dégâts sont importants
de nombreux habitations étaient touchées
provoquant des dégâts matériels le maire
de la ville va demander un arrêté de
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle dans l'actualité également
Gabriel la ville de Bois-d'Arcy qui va
lancer un appel à bénévole oui alors
vous le savez on est en plein Tour de
France et vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
non plus que les coureurs parce qu'on
dans les Yvelines pour la 110e édition
du Tour le 23 juillet 50 ans en Yvelines
fait office de ville départ les coureurs
partiront du vélo de Drôme national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et passeront
par plusieurs villes hyblinoises comme
Fontenay-le-Fleury et l'encourt ou
encore plaisir à Bois-d'Arcy les
coureurs passeront à 16 heures pour
l'événement la ville est recherche d'une
dizaine de bénévoles selon nos confrères
de cette actu leur mission tenir des
points de sécurité sur le parcours entre
midi et 18h alors si vous êtes intéressé
les contacts s'affichent en bas de votre
écran et après le Tour de France la
prochaine grande étape sportive sur le
territoire ce sont les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 et là c'est 50 ans en
Yvelines qui a la recherche de bénévoles
oui un appel à projet qui vise à tenir
les initiatives locales pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris est lancé la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines prévoit une
enveloppe de 450 000 euros pour l'appel
à projet intitulé faire bouger Sky en
route vers les Jeux olympiques de Paris
alors cette enveloppe elle permet de
soutenir les acteurs qu'ils soient
associatifs amateurs ou encore
professionnel à s'investir pour faire de
ces jeux une réussite l'objectif c'est
faire de 2024 une année festive et de
promouvoir le sport sur Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines où se dérouleront vous le savez
plusieurs épreuves on revient maintenant
sur une initiative solidaire organisée
par la CGT et le MODEF oui vendre des
produits paysans directement du
producteur au consommateur sans
intermédiaire c'était le but de
l'opération organisée par la CGT des
Yvelines et le modem syndicap paysan
progressiste ce vendredi 7 juillet on
écoute le secrétaire général de la CGT
Yvelines au micro de Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude l'idée c'était qu'on se
rencontre nous milieux ouvriers et eux
milieux paysan en disant bah on est des
deux bouts de la chaîne et on va squiser
le milieu et montrer qu'on arrive à
faire de la vente solidaire a pris juste
c'est-à-dire après qui rémunère les
exploitants et qui puissent vivre de
leur travail et que nous en tant qu'a
consommateur on ne paye pas des marges
importantes et donc du coup on arrive
pour pas cher et moins cher que dans les
grandes surfaces à manger doivent des
produits de meilleure qualité
alors la vente de fruits et de légumes
avaient lieu devant la gare de Trappes
elle a attiré de nombreux trappistes et
des habitants des quartiers populaires
d'après la CGT des Yvelines c'est plus
d'une tonne de produits paysans qui ont
été vendus l'expérience donc c'était la
première année pour cette expérience
cette expérience elle devrait être
renouvelée dans les mois à venir et on
termine ces informations du jour Gabriel
avec une bonne nouvelle pour le zoo
safari de Thoiry oui le zoo vient de
communiquer sur de nouvelles naissances
celle de deux bébés oryx al gazelle né
en mai dernier un événement pour le parc
et pour cause Mathilde lorix al Gazelle
est un est une espèce aujourd'hui très
rare originaire du nord de l'Afrique
l'espèce s'est éteinte à l'état sauvage
le but du zoo maintenant et la
réintroduction de l'espèce dans son
milieu naturel et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel bontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
top départ pour les grandes vacances
d'été cette semaine avec la chaleur les
plans d'eau sont pris d'assaut dans les
Yvelines à l'île de loisirs des Boucles
de Seine des milliers de visiteurs vont
se prélasser sur la plage et dans l'eau
chaque année il est donc important de
rappeler certains gestes à adopter pour
éviter les noyades et ce week-end la
Macif a donné rendez-vous aux familles
l'objectif les sensibiliser au risque
liés à la baignade et les initiés aux
gestes de premiers secours c'est le
reportage de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Céline Charles
un soleil de plomb et une plage de sable
fin difficile de résister à la tentation
en période estivale les bords de lac
sont toujours pris d'assaut l'occasion
de rappeler certains gestes à adopter
pour que petit et grands puissent se
baigner en toute sécurité au plan d'eau
de l'île de loisirs des boucles de scène
l'assurance la Macif a organisé une
opération de prévention quel risque liés
au soleil on n'est jamais évité de se
faire brûler éviter de rentrer dans
l'eau directement parce que c'est très
violent il y a les risques liés à tout
ce qui est addiction diverses et variées
ils prennent conscience qu'il y a des
risques et que ça devienne finalement
des réflexes au plus tard pour que ils
soient vigilant que même si on fait on
joue on fait moins attention on a quand
même quelques réflexes de type
prévention
identifier les risques du plan d'eau
connaître les bons réflexes en cas
d'accident ou encore s'initier aux
gestes de premiers secours l'objectif
était de sensibiliser les parents comme
les enfants Thomas sapeur-pompier
volontaire dans le Val-d'Oise était sur
place pour dispenser aux estivants des
notions de secourisme
en alternance avec le massage cardiaque
pour faire après c'est facile ces deux
étapes consécutives
ce qu'on vient de faire 30 compression
il va falloir vérifier son état de
conscience c'est le plus important dans
un premier temps et ensuite si
malheureusement elle est inconsciente ce
qui risque d'être le cas en cas de
noyade prendre la respiration et puis
deux cas de figure se s'offrent à nous
heureusement elle respire il va falloir
faire en sorte qu'elle continue à
respirer donc la mettre sur le côté
puisque le danger est de mort si on la
laisse à plein d'eau et si elle ne
respire pas et bien de toute façon va
falloir maintenir une respiration de
manière artificielle en réalisant un
massage cardiaque tout le monde devrait
être formé à ses premiers ces gestes de
premiers secours parce que ça peut
arriver en fait un accident arrive par
nature un accident on peut on sait
jamais quand ça arrive donc en cas de
situation d'urgence n'hésitez pas à
alerter le poste de secours le plus
proche ou bien composé le 15 ou le 18 en
juin 2023 233 cas de noyade dont 80
mortelles ont été recensés en France
direction Magny-les-Hameaux à présent en
en parlait en début d'émission un
collectif de citoyens s'est formé en mai
dernier il demande l'enfouissement des
lignes à haute tension sur le quartier
du buisson pour en parler avec nous le
fondateur Pierre-Louis Brière et deux
membres du collectif Laetitia Marlin
bonsoir et Emmanuel boucher bonsoir
alors Laetitia Marlin Emmanuel boucher
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé
d'intégrer ce collectif
comme vous voulez pour ma part en fait
voilà moi je suis habitante à
Magny-les-Hameaux depuis 2018 et ce qui
se passe c'est qu'en gros on est juste
en dessous vraiment des lignes
c'est vrai que bon bah déjà bon certes
ça fait pas très joli dans le paysage
mais ça peut être dangereux et c'est
vrai que ce qu'on nous a appris c'est
que depuis 2018 depuis que je suis
arrivée quand j'ai emménagé là-bas ce
qui se passe c'est que tous les
habitants enfin les anciens
propriétaires tout le monde nous a dit
ça doit être fait ça doit être fait mais
en gros ils ont vendu du rêve et au
final tout le monde se retrouve à se
dire mais il y aurait dû avoir quelque
chose de fait au final rien ne se fait
et maintenant mais c'est vraiment les
gens sont blasés déçus et enfin limite
on a du mal à les faire limite rentrer
dans le collectif parce qu'au final ils
y croient plus et c'est vraiment dommage
et on est là et on essaie vraiment de
les motiver ce sont les mêmes raisons
pour vous Emmanuel raison moi je suis
moins touché ce que je suis pas dans ce
quartier là de Magny-les-Hameaux je suis
un tout petit peu plus loin mais c'est
surtout pour souvenir le collectif ce
qu'on est tous ensemble même si je peux
toucher directement et essayer de faire
en sorte que ce soit nombreux plus lié
de voix pour tenir garde cause entre
guillemets ça t'enfouissement alors en
début d'émission vous nous parliez des
risques sanitaires liés à ces lignes à
haute tension quels sont les risques et
il y a eu des études qui l'ont qui l'ont
prouvé oui donc dans tous les rapports
officiels donc il y a des risques qui
sont mentionnés les risques notamment de
leucémie infantile de cancer infantile
qui nous concerne particulièrement vu
que la ligne passe au dessus de la
crèche l'école maternelle le gymnase les
aires de jeux pour enfants donc il y a
pas de consensus sur ces risques mais
ils sont toujours évoqués ce qui suffit
à nous inquiéter
on parle notamment de cas de le signe
infantile qui aurait eu dans le quartier
depuis quelques années on peut pas
prouver que c'est dû à ça mais c'est
qu'à existent existe
donc ça c'est vraiment la première
raison pour laquelle on se mobilise il y
a aussi des risques d'effondrement c'est
une deuxième raison il y a le risque de
sécurité oui la ligne elle s'est déjà
décrochée et elle est tombée dans la
cour de l'école André Gide lors de la
tempête de 1999 et avec le dérèglement
climatique qui arrive c'est des risques
qui sont de plus en plus probables donc
voilà ça n'a plus trop de sens de vivre
avec une épée d'amoclès au dessus de la
tête elle a également le bruit
présent constamment exactement
c'est aussi une nuisance sonore donc
c'est aussi une question de cadre de vie
donc Laetitia toi tu habites juste en
dessous donc j'imagine que tu es plus
concerné que moi par Google
fréquemment on a remarqué alors qu'en
tant humide il y a ces petits
grésillements et il y a encore ben
justement je suis envoyé la petite vidéo
ça peut être le soir en pleine nuit donc
là on est en plein été il fait très
chaud les fenêtres sont forcément
ouvertes et il y a ce grésillement alors
il y a des fois ça va être aléatoire il
y a des fois ça va être beaucoup plus
souvent enfin ça peut être limite
constant et c'est vrai que 10 heures
quand il y a plus de bruit entendre
c'est pas grave du tout et c'est vrai
qu'on se dit mais voilà mais au final
qu'est-ce que ça fait sur nous parce que
il y a un moment vraiment on se pose des
questions moi je peux rajouter il y a
vraiment enfin on se pose de plus en
plus de questions aussi là dessus c'est
que dans ma rue donc tous ceux qui sont
arrivés on va dire depuis 20 à 40 ans et
tout premier qui était là
il y en a qui peuvent tomber gravement
malade alors encore une fois ça vient
pas forcément que de ça mais quelle est
l'influence on se pose vraiment la
question quelle est l'influence on va
dire sur les personnes qui tombent
malades qui a pu avoir ces lignes aux
tensions et ces lignes il y a 20 ans
elles étaient déjà présentes est-ce que
vous savez l'historique un peu de ces
lignes à haute tension alors on sait
qu'elle se sont là depuis au moins 40
ans
qui a un projet d'enfouissement qui
existe depuis
au moins 20 ans je dirais
voilà qui a failli faire à plusieurs
reprises et finalement le finalement ça
s'est pas fait
je sais pas exactement il y a eu
plusieurs revirements il y a plusieurs
communes notamment de l'agglomération
qui sont demandeuses de l'enfouissement
et c'est quand même des c'est quand même
des dossiers assez onéreux
donc voilà nous on est là justement pour
cette enfouissement se fasse pour qu'il
y ait une vraie mobilisation citoyenne
sur la ville qui sont en relais aussi
des demandes plus politiques
de la mairie oui oui le maire je l'ai
rencontré plusieurs fois il soutient
évidemment la démarche mais voilà on a
convenu de rester chacun dans son
couloir nous on est vraiment un
collectif citoyen et mobilisation
citoyenne apolitique et lui dans un
couloir plus politique et je pense que
c'est complémentaire notamment auprès
des principaux acteurs décisionnaires
sur ce dossier et justement RTE le
réseau de transport d'électricité vous
l'avez également contacté alors en fait
là on est plutôt dans une phase de
structuration interne pour être crédible
donc grandir être de nombreux
aussi voilà on est ici enfin on mobilise
aussi la presse locale on a eu un
article dans la Gazette de 50 ans en
Yvelines dans les nouvelles de cette
semaine normalement on a reçu un article
aussi pour se crédibiliser aussi en
interne par rapport aux membres du
collectif et au menu quoi qui comme
disait Laetitia sont parfois un peu
désabusés sur le sujet et après on va
entrer dans la troisième phase qui est
celle des rendez-vous donc très
prochainement avec l'agglomération qui
est de très bonne volonté pour ré-ouvrir
le dossier et donc ensuite on ira voir
avec l'agglomération RTE pour
pouvoir voir concrètement comment on
fait et après on ira voir les principaux
partenaires notamment le département et
la région pour voir les financements et
on essaiera d'avoir un calendrier
d'enfouissement le plus vite possible
mais voilà c'est un combat de longue
haleine donc on fait les étapes les unes
après les autres pour maximiser les
chances d'enfouissement pour le moment
pas de prise de contact avec RTE ni le
département des Yvelines ou quand même
une prise de contact
à la rentrée
et vous le disiez il y a quelques
instants c'est un sujet qui date
d'énormément d'années d'y a plus de 20
ans notamment sur plusieurs villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
également Élancourt et la verrière
est-ce que vous avez pensé à vous unir à
d'autres habitants qui vivent la même
chose pour justement peser plus lourd
alors
j'ai pas eu de contact j'ai pas
connaissance de collectif
similaire
à Élancourt et la verrière
bien que leur dossier soit plus avancé
que les nôtres donc on est plutôt
contacté par les habitants de Saint-Rémy
au moins 15 20 qui nous ont contactés
c'est le prolongement de notre ligne ça
passe au dessus du des Hauts de
Saint-Rémy du quartier de beau plan et U
aimerait faire d'une pierre deux coups
et que
bénéficier aussi de l'enfouissement donc
on les accueille à bras ouverts merci
beaucoup Pierre Louis Brière Laetitia
Marlin et Emmanuel Bouchet d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes membre du
Collectif citoyen pour l'enfouissement
des lignes à haute tension de Manille
les hameaux allez c'est l'heure à
présent d'ouvrir une page sport dans
votre 7 8
[Musique]
et pour ouvrir cette page port nous vous
proposons un portrait Olivier de
Robillard Saint-Germain de 53 ans on va
participer aux championnat mondiaux de
natation au Japon il se dérouleront du 2
au 11 août Gabriel Gonthier l'a suivi
lors d'un de ses entraînements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6h du matin piscine de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye est déjà quelques
courageux dans l'eau
[Musique]
parmi eux Olivier de Robillard à 53 ans
le saint-germain-nois se prépare au
mondiaux de natation qui se dérouleront
au Japon dans quelques semaines au
programme une heure d'entraînement avec
son coach le nageur kaaris miette
une minute donc on a pas beaucoup de
temps de repos
et le but c'est d'essayer d'avoir le
même temps à chaque fois c'est parti
pour le 50m nage libre et après de
longues années loin des bassins le
nageur a conservé le goût de l'effort
c'est dur sur le moment mais
après on est bien
pour Olivier reprendre la natation est
apparu comme une évidence natation ça a
toujours fait partie de ma vie j'ai
commencé à nager très très jeune j'ai un
peu laissé tomber et j'ai découvert par
hasard il y a 5 ans que les masters
c'était pas fait que pour de la nage
loisirs mes clients aussi des
compétitions d'organiser et ça a été
pour moi le déclic pour pour reprendre
et un jour je suis rentré à la maison et
j'ai annoncé à la famille qu'est-ce qui
penserait de que leur papa
participent au championnats du monde de
natation au Japon ça serait l'occasion
de faire un beau voyage avec un
événement plutôt sympathique à la fin
l'objectif pour le quinquagénaire se
classer en milieu de tableau mais
surprendre du plaisir qu'un porte le
résultat le soutien et la fierté du
coach reste indéfectible c'est un
bosseur c'est quelqu'un qui a pas peur
d'affronter
la dureté des entraînements en sachant
que bon je suis pas le plus facile sur
ce sujet c'est quelqu'un qui est très
allé sur les longues distances et donc
là voilà je pense que le le 100 m c'est
vraiment un beau challenge pour lui le
sport
if sa famille pour
de 100 mètres nage libre
on poursuit cette page sport avec les
résultats sportifs à retenir du week-end
c'est avec vous Michael el midoro et on
commence par du basket après un premier
match compliqué avec les Spurs ce
livinois Victor weba nyama s'est
ressaisis ce dimanche il a inscrit 27
points pris 12 rebonds et à réaliser
trois contre en seulement 27 minutes de
jeu un premier double double sous le
maillot de San Antonio mais wembi est
sorti contrarier car il n'a pas pu
offrir la victoire à son équipe face à
Portland lors de la summerling
compétition amicale à Las Vegas son
équipe s'est inclinée 85 à 80 le géant
de 2 mètres 21 veut maintenant se
reposer après un marathon médiatique de
trois semaines suite à la draft pour
préparer au mieux la saison prochaine un
marathon médiatique et une polémique
insolite nickel également pour One
banyama c'était la semaine dernière oui
le nom de webanyama était associé à
celui de Britney Spears Mathilde la
semaine dernière l'ancienne star de la
pop aurait pris une gifle de la part de
la sécurité des Spurs sont tentant de
prendre une photo avec la nouvelle star
des Spurs à Las Vegas on l'a tapé sur
l'épaule et ça énervé le service de
sécurité lui ne l'a pas vu parce qu'il
marchait tout droit d'après ses dires la
chanteuse de 41 ans a déposé une main
courante pour couper blessures vendredi
la police de Las Vegas a décidé de ne
retenir aucune charge après visionnage
des images en tout cas cette histoire
montre la nouvelle dimension médiatique
de Victor webmail on l'aurait jamais cru
il y a quelques mois et pauvre Britney
Spears on va maintenant quitter les
États-Unis Michael pour partir en
Angleterre en tennis Caroline Garson
remportera pas le prestigieux tournoi de
Wimbledon la joueuse originaire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ses inclinés au
troisième tour contre la Tchèque Marie
au bouskova le score 7 6 4 6 7 5 c'est
une nouvelle déception pour Caroline
Garcia après sa défaite au deuxième tour
de Roland-Garros il n'y a plus divinois
Wimbledon l'autre sans Germanois Arthur
Rinder knash avait perdu au premier tour
contre Alexandre Muller et on poursuit
avec du football le mercato a ouvert
l'occasion pour les équipes de se
renforcer le FC à Versailles très actif
sur le marché des transferts samedi
Jules row jeune gardien de 19 ans en
provenance du LOSC a signé au club il a
notamment été champion de France en 2021
en tant que 3e gardien à Lille ce n'est
pas le seul joueur qui a signé il y a
Lassana Diakhaby le défenseur de
Martigues de 27 ans qui arrive Kevin
Mbala attaquant de 22 ans en provenance
du Paris FC il a marqué 11 buts en 16
matchs Kevin nager un milieu de terrain
né en 2001 rejoint aussi la cité royale
et enfin Djibril la Bangoura ami
offensive de 21 ans il a été élu
meilleur joueur de la poule A de
Nationale 2 et le PSG c'est également
renforcé ce week-end deux joueurs ont
rejoint officiellement le PSG ce
week-end le milieu offensif licorne in
formé à lance à passer bah est passé
également par Majorque et la quatrième
recrue estivale du club francilien le
Paris Saint-Germain va débourser 22
millions d'euros le PSG a aussi
officialisé la venue du défenseur
Champion du Monde 2018 lu Hernandez en
provenance du Bayern Munich le joueur de
27 ans a signé pour 5 ans le Bayern
Munich va toucher 50 millions d'euros
bonus compris il s'entraîneront cette
semaine du côté du nouveau centre
d'entraînement à Poissy et ça a repris
aujourd'hui et bien merci beaucoup
Mickaël midoro pour toutes ces
informations on poursuit cette page
sport avec un autre portrait à présent
sur un sport plus ou moins insolite le
poker depuis 15 ans Sylvie Becquart
habitant de Voisins le bretonneux joue à
ce fameux jeu de bluff l'année dernière
à la même remporté le titre de
championne de France par équipe sur un
site internet spécialisé mais pour
Sylvie rien ne remplace le contact
humain lors des tournois physiques
Julien Leroy nous dresse le portrait de
cette compétitrice dans l'âme
là j'ai as Valais je me pose même plus
de questions ces boîtes quoi qu'il
arrive parce que techniquement il me
reste 4,8 bébé Sylvie 60 ans est une
vraie passionnée de poker cet habitant
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux découvre son
appétence pour ce jeu en 2008 grâce à
son mari inscrit à l'association
vicinoise NH poker team bluff fold ou
confly
et à prendre des techniques nouvelles
deux ans plus tard elle lance avec son
époux le Frenz Poker Club à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la meilleure
école pour nous c'était d'aller jouer
dans les tournois extérieurs et
rencontrer des nouvelles personnes quand
on est dans une association on joue tout
le temps avec les mêmes personnes au
bout d'un moment on se connaît et on
avance plus dans la progression de notre
façon de jouer au poker une armoire
garnie de trophées cette ancienne
cavalière équestre pendant 30 ans à
garder son esprit de compétition en 2022
elle obtient le titre de championne de
France par équipe avec ses trois
coéquipiers sur un site internet
spécialisé malgré tout Sylvie n'a jamais
souhaité atteindre un niveau
professionnel c'est un monde à part
c'est aller jouer dans tout dans le
monde entier moi l'argent ça me fait
peur en fait j'ai pas envie d'y laisser
ma chemise ma maison perdre mon couple
perdre ma famille et rentrer dans
l'addiction
[Musique]
les tournefeuilles physiques des moments
privilégiés pour développer pleinement
son talent ses qualités une bonne
analyse des autres concurrents et
beaucoup de patience avec une stratégie
bien à elle moi je parle beaucoup sur
une table de poker donc je déstabilise
les autres joueurs qui pensent que je
les regarde pas mais en fait tout en
parlant j'observe les joueurs autour de
moi elle est devenue plus mordu que moi
elle est devenue meilleur que moi donc
voilà quoi elle a des résultats que j'ai
jamais réussi à avoir donc tu peux dire
que tu es fier d'elle complètement
Sylvie participera la prochaine
compétition France Poker Series du 15 au
23 juillet à Paris les sports de
décrocher un nouveau titre d'envergure
face à plusieurs centaines de joueurs
on va parler maintenant d'une thématique
qui concerne de plus en plus de sportifs
la préparation mentale pour en parler
avec nous Jean-Christophe Maisonneuve
vous avez préparé mentalement les
joueurs du club de volley-ball de
Conflans Andrésy Jouy pendant plusieurs
années et vous venez de sortir un livre
intitulé la performance d'une vie qui
est parue aux éditions Le Lys bleu alors
l'idée générale c'est de prendre du
recul sur son parcours de vie pour en
tirer ses forces est-ce que vous pouvez
nous pitcher un petit peu en quelques en
quelques secondes votre livre
en quelques mots la performance d'une
vie aurait pu être intitulé
effectivement transformer les douleurs
du passé pour en faire les forces
d'aujourd'hui c'est
[Musique]
avec mon exemple de vie qui est ni pire
ni mieux que tout à chacun c'est comment
on peut transformer ce que j'ai vécu les
moments émotionnellement fort de ma vie
et en faire des éléments forts
aujourd'hui des éléments positifs qui
soient plutôt en train à me faire
progresser plutôt que de me ralentir les
événements de vie
peuvent être liés à l'éducation à avoir
connu la maladie le deuil
l'addiction enfin tout ce genre de
choses les problèmes d'éducation les
problèmes qu'on peut rencontrer avec ses
parents et on peut traîner ça pendant
des années et des années pendant sa vie
l'objectif c'est moi j'ai traîné
certaines choses pendant plus de 30 ans
voire 40 ans l'objectif c'est que je
puisse communiquer les clés que j'ai
aujourd'hui grâce à la préparation
mentale pour permettre à tout à chacun
de se débarrasser de ça le plus
rapidement possible et en faire une
vraie force de faire ce livre
alors je vous cache pas que ça a été une
sorte de psychothérapie l'écriture j'ai
découvert l'écriture à ce moment là j'ai
commencé il y a un an
et c'est vrai que le fait d'écrire c'est
automatiquement prendre du recul sur ce
qu'on a vécu
moi j'imaginais pas non plus qu'on
pouvait se souvenir de tout et en
écrivant tous les souvenirs reviennent
ce qui permet de revivre les choses
comme on les a comme on les a vécu mais
avec le recul nécessaire et puis une
fois que le livre est édité là on
se débarrasse de son histoire on a
vraiment la hauteur nécessaire et on
peut justement avancer avec alors
justement ce livre Michael on l'a devant
nos yeux
on l'a tous au total il y a il y a 12
leçons 12 conseils quels sont-ils
c'est
comment comment gérer alors il y a plein
de petits conseils issus de la
préparation mentale mais pas que ce sont
j'ai surtout écrit ça en fonction de mes
expériences d'accompagnement et pas
seulement avec des sportifs aussi avec
des entrepreneurs j'ai fait le constat
que pour des symptômes un petit peu
identiques la perte de confiance la
gestion du stress lors d'une prise de
parole en public ou lors du regard de
l'autre la peur du regard de l'autre
tous ces doutes toutes ces peurs sont
liées à des phénomènes qui sont à peu
près similaires et du coup c'est
travailler sur la notion d'abandon la
notion du regard de l'autre la notion du
comment se détache de ce que l'autre une
personne référente a pu dire sur vous un
prof un parent un entraîneur quand on
est petit et quel impact ça sur soi
pendant des années et des années donc
c'est ça les clés que je vais chercher
je vais pas tout vous les donner parce
que oui c'est quand même un livre de
développement personnel alors c'est un
pavé comme on peut et il faut pas être
psychologue pour le lire l'objectif
c'est qu'il soit accessible à tous
aux sportif comme aux autres comme au
littéraire
et pour que il soit facile à intégrer
les clés sont assez faciles à intégrer à
mettre en place au quotidien et après
évidemment ce n'est que une prise de
conscience c'est pas des clés ou ça y
est on se débarrasse du problème je suis
pas psychologue je ne vais pas cette
vocation donc c'est vraiment comment
aujourd'hui on pose son fardeau et on
avance alors que psychologue va plus
travailler sur le traumatisme pour
régler vraiment le traumatisme qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez que les gens
retiennent de ce livre
j'aimerais comme j'ai déjà eu des
retours d'ailleurs vous voulez faire
progresser oui dans leur vie voilà c'est
si je peux rayonner de façon beaucoup
plus grande auprès des autres c'est
vraiment leur donner des clés pour pour
leur permettre de vivre au mieux qu'ils
sont parce que l'objectif en préparation
mentale c'est d'aider les sportifs ou
autre à mieux se connaître pour mieux
réagir en fonction de telle ou telle
situation si je sais que sous pression
je réagis comme ça qu'est-ce que je mets
en place comme stratégie pour éviter de
perdre ma lucidité ou de succomber au
stress ou de m'énerver ou autre donc
c'est vraiment leur permettre de mieux
se connaître d'aller chercher le plus
loin possible
pour pour vivre
l'instant présent de façon le plus
épanouissant possible et en 120 pages on
y arrive à la fin alors 130
on a les bases on a les bases et on peut
après rien n'empêche de m'appeler pour
pour aller plus loin alors vous allez
donner de nombreux conseils à des
équipes sportives et notamment au club
de volley-ball de Conflans
expliquez-nous un petit peu comment vous
avez travaillé avec eux tout au long de
ces années alors j'ai travaillé des
meilleures équipes de France et en tout
cas c'est la meilleure équipe du
département en volley-ball c'est ça ils
sont en élite en élite c'est-à-dire
juste en dessous des professionnels
ça fait trois ans maintenant que que
j'accompagne Conflans deux années assez
présent pour vraiment inculquer des
réflexes de de préparation on pense à la
fixation d'objectif routine de
performance des routines de au service
des routines de préparation
comment on se prépare juste avant un
match comme on arrive à se concentrer à
se donner de l'énergie et puis au final
les joueurs tournent ce sont pas les
mêmes d'une année à l'autre par contre
le coach est toujours le même donc
c'était aussi de travailler dans le fond
avec le coach avec leur entraîneur et ce
travail là a porté ses fruits au fur et
à mesure parce que lui il est là tout le
temps il commence à inculquer les les
bons réflexes aux joueurs et cette année
j'ai principalement été rappelé
justement pour les phases finales pour
un non plus un travail de fond qui avait
déjà été mené mais vraiment un travail
ponctuel sur OK on est en phase finale
comment l'équipe quel discours on peut
avoir entre joueurs pour gérer ces
moments qui peuvent être des moments de
stress qui vont être des moments
compliqués à gérer et c'était comment
eux sur place sur le terrain à l'instant
t ils vont pouvoir
sauvegarder les uns les autres et ne pas
s'enfoncer mais on pourrait retrouver
les ressources en chacun d'entre eux et
puis en eux-mêmes pour pour tirer le
meilleur et le résultat c'est que
comment se mettre dans sa bulle aussi
pour être concentré pour donner le
meilleur de soi-même comment se mettre
dans sa bulle mais dans ces moments-là
la force elle vient du collectif si la
personne reste isolée on s'isole aussi
d'un groupe on est sur un sport
collectif et l'important là dans cette
situation là était vraiment d'aller
puiser sa force quand on est un peu
limite justement chez les autres et
alors comment on fait pour puiser sa
force quels conseils vous donner
concrètement là typiquement c'était de
profiter des temps morts par exemple
d'avoir un discours de rester concentré
donc ne pas aller chercher ne pas
discuter avec son voisin etc mais de
rester focus sur une ou deux consignes
que le coach qu'on soit capable de
d'écouter aussi de retrouver sa
concentration de respirer ensemble pour
se aligner en termes d'énergie et
repartir tous au même niveau et
de façon à être tout de suite efficace
au moment où on retourne sur le terrain
et quand on est sur le terrain c'est ça
va être beaucoup de non-verbal comment
on regarde sans coéquipier si il a fait
une boulette comment on va le soutenir
plutôt que l'enfoncer et le langage
non-verbal est très important pour ça et
ça fonctionne avec tous les joueurs
vraiment
avec tous les joueurs ouverts
réceptifs que d'autres oui alors c'est
vraiment avec des joueurs ouverts
d'esprit il y a des joueurs pour qui le
mindset et quelque chose d'acquis et qui
se travaille pas forcément ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont être meilleur ou moins
bons ça veut juste dire qu'ils
travaillent ils ont pas forcément les
les mêmes bases pour moi ça se travaille
avec pour tout le monde maintenant tout
le monde va être réceptif plus ou moins
à ce genre de choses et vous avez
adressé seulement les équipes de haut
niveau ou vous faites également des
sportifs dans votre quotidien alors je
le fais avec tout type de sportifs et de
niveau sportif ce qui est intéressant
avec le sport de niveau c'est que les
joueurs se connaissent déjà beaucoup ils
ont déjà beaucoup travaillé sur eux ils
sont déjà retrouvés dans des situations
particulièrement stressantes avec des
enjeux importants et on a affaire à des
gens qui ont vraiment une connaissance
de leur réaction de leurs émotions en
fonction de telle ou tel stress et c'est
intéressant parce que le travail est
très efficace à ce niveau là et
qu'est-ce qui est dur au tout début
quand on commence
c'est de
trouver entre guillemets l'efficacité de
la préparation mentale de prouver alors
ça a été fait par les neurosciences
aujourd'hui on sait que ce qu'on dit
c'est pas un travail de gourou on sait
que les neurosciences sont prouvés les
choses il y a des choses qui sont dans
ce livre et qui sont prouvées et que je
cite mais il y a convaincre convaincre
son son audience et je pourrai avoir
fait une conférence il y a deux ans à
l'INSEP avec leur antily qui était
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de France de
volley avec Didier Dinard qui était wand
et puis l'adjointe Didier Deschamps on
s'est rendu compte que le discours par
rapport à la préparation mentale n'est
pas le même qu'il y en a un au foot où
on dit bah ça c'est le job de Didier
Deschamps et c'est lui qui s'occupe de
ça
Didier Dinard il dit mais nous au hand
on peut même pas envisager que un
Karabatic par exemple puisse avoir un
problème mental sinon c'est tout de
suite le psy sauf qu'on n'est pas des
psy encore une fois on ne gère pas un
joueur quand il va pas bien et il y
avait Laurent Tilly qui au contraire
était très à l'écoute de ça très ouvert
à ça la preuve en est c'est qu'il a pris
quelqu'un je me souviens après cette
cette conférence à l'INSEP qui était
dédiée à la performance et que trois
mois après il était
qualifiés pour les JO dont on connaît la
suite qui est encore du travail à faire
du travail de sensibilisation ça vient
de plus en plus les JO approche et c'est
surtout qu'on a aujourd'hui des sportifs
qui osent en parler un teddy Riner qui
en parle depuis plusieurs années mais
aujourd'hui même à l'international des
djokovics ou une asiatique pour parler
du tennis parle plus ouvertement de leur
préparation mentale de ce qu'ils font et
de l'impact que ça dans leur sport
est-ce qu'on voit des vrais résultats
sur sur les sportifs
oui vraiment alors déjà je pense pour le
tournoi d'Andrésy j'ai encore eu le
coach tout à l'heure au téléphone qui a
vraiment senti la différence les
demi-finales et finales qu'ils ont fait
en Coupe de France c'était des matchs de
presque 3 heures où ils ont été
systématiquement menés au score c'est
des matchs qui auraient pu tourner alors
des avantages à n'importe quel moment
ils ont su trouver les ressources je dis
pas que je suis la clé de ça mais ils
ont été chercher par rapport à ce que
j'avais pu leur dire ou ce qu'ils
avaient des choses dont ils ont pu
prendre conscience
ils ont mis en place des des
fonctionnements qui ont fait qu'ils ont
trouvé les ressources pour ne jamais
baisser les bras et pour être au dessus
alors évidemment ils sont peut-être
mieux préparés physiquement et autres
mais en tout cas ça a fonctionné et
aujourd'hui quand je travaille avec un
sportif ou un entrepreneur le résultat
il dépasse le simple résultat sportif ou
résultat financiers c'est souvent les
retours que j'ai la clé d'entrée ça va
être un problème de concentration ou de
lucidité pour un joueur ou un problème
par rapport à une prise de parole en
public pour un entrepreneur et au final
quand on finit de travailler après trois
à six mois on se retrouve avec des gens
qui rayonnent qui sont radieux qui vont
voir le positif dans toutes les choses
et du coup qui arrive à rebondir
beaucoup plus facilement et mettre en
place des choses bien plus positives
autour d'eux le positif amène le positif
merci beaucoup Jean-Christophe
Maisonneuve d'avoir été notre invité sur
ce plateau votre livre la performance
d'une vie parue aux éditions le lise
bleu est disponible si vous êtes si vous
vous intéressez à la préparation mentale
et avant de se quitter un peu de
légèreté jusqu'au 16 juillet la ville de
Coignières fête l'été avec des
animations gratuites pour toute la
famille c'est ce que propose l'opérer
l'opération un été à Coignières dont la
cinquième édition a début a débuté ce
samedi c'est le reportage de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude et Jeannel mart in
château gonflable toboggan ou encore
poney les familles et les jeunes de la
ville de Coignières ont pu dès ce samedi
profiter des animations organisées par
la mairie un événement essentiel pour
les habitants selon le maire Didier
Fisher c'est très apprécié des jeunes et
des familles parce que c'est un moment
vous le voyez convivial ou les parents
viennent avec leurs enfants et ça se
passe bien il y a des jeux il y a des
structures gonflables c'est devenu un
rendez-vous incontournable et il
l'attendent il l'attendent comme vous le
dites tout à l'heure tout le monde part
pas en vacances malheureusement donc
c'est un peu des vacances quoi en plus
des animations organisées en journée les
coins ni rien peuvent profiter de soirée
à thème comme la soirée Dj magicien ou
encore barbecue pour les familles le
succès semble déjà être au rendez-vous
par rapport à d'autres choses qu'on a pu
voir dans d'autres villes je trouve que
c'est très bien c'est très encadré dès
que je peux oui je viens c'est quelque
chose qui permet à la communauté de se
retrouver les enfants vu qu'ils se
connaissent tous à l'école donc
forcément ils se retrouvent leurs
copains copines
un événement festif et convivial qui se
tient jusqu'au 16 juillet au gymnase du
moulin à vent à Coignières
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir un
grand soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau
des températures il fera 20 degrés à
Rambouillet 21 à Houdan 22 à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 23 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le ciel se couvre
légèrement côté température il fera
chaud en moyenne 30 à 31 degrés et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]